AHEAD THIS MORNING.
>>> BUT WE BEGIN THIS MORNING
WITH A SIGN OF LIFE RETURNING TO
PRE-PANDEMIC NORMALCY.
ON FRIDAY, MANY AMERICANS WENT
MASKLESS IN PUBLIC FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MONTHS.
A DAY AFTER THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL RELAXED ITS
GUIDELINES ON FACE COVERINGS FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED.
18 STATES ANNOUNCED PLANS TO
DROP PUBLIC MASK MANDATES EITHER
IMMEDIATELY OR IN THE WEEKS TO
COME.
OTHERS SUCH AS CALIFORNIA, NEW
YORK, AND NEW JERSEY ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH CAUTION.
THE CHANGES COME AS NEARLY HALF
OF AMERICANS HAVE RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE OF A COVID-19
VACCINE, WHILE MORE THAN
ONE-THIRD ARE FULLY VACCINATED.
AS THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF NEW
CASES SLIPS BELOW 35,000, THE
LOWEST SINCE SEPTEMBER, BUT
WHILE PROGRESS IS BEING MADE,
AMERICANS EAGER TO ENJOY SPRING
WEATHER ARE RECEIVING MIXED
MESSAGES ABOUT MASKING.
MICHAEL GEORGE HAS THE STORY.
GOOD MORNING, MICHAEL.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
TO BE CLEAR, WHAT THE CDC PUT
OUT ARE JUST GUIDELINES ON MASK
WEARING, LEAVING IT UP TO
STATES, STORES, SPORTS VENUES
AND THE REST TO DECIDE IF MASKS
ARE REQUIRED.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN MIRRORS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC -- A PATCHWORK OF RULES
THAT VARY FROM PLACE TO PLACE.
THE CDC'S NEW GUIDELINES
SPECIFICALLY APPLY TO VACCINATED
PEOPLE.
>> PEOPLE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED
SHOULD NOT BE TAKING OFF THEIR
MASKS.
>> Reporter: THE GUIDELINES
ISSUED AS CASES WENT DOWN BY A
THIRD LAST WEEK AND VACCINATIONS
AGAIN INCREASED WERE LEFT OPEN
TO INTERPRETATION.
>> THE STATE OF NORTH CAROLINA
WILL NO LONGER REQUIRE YOU TO
WEAR A MASK.
>> Reporter: BUT --
>> THERE WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
MANDATORY INDOOR MASK
REQUIREMENT ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, IN CHILDCARE, IN
SCHOOLS, IN PRISONS, AND IN
CERTAIN PUBLIC HEALTH SETTINGS.
>> Reporter: COLORADO TOOK A
BROADER VIEW --
>> WE HAVE REACHED A THRESHOLD
WHERE NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE ARE
VACCINATED TO END THE PANDEMIC,
BUT ENOUGH PEOPLE ARE VACCINATED
WHERE ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
VACCINATED NO LONGER NEED TO
WEAR MASKS.
>> Reporter: AND CORPORATIONS
MADE UP THEIR OWN RULES.
KROGER, TARGET, AND HOME DEPOT
SAY THEY'RE KEEPING MASK
MANDATES IN PLACE.
BUT WALMART AND TRADER JOE'S
WON'T REQUIRE MASKS FOR
VACCINATED CUSTOMERS.
THEY WON'T ASK FOR PROOF OF
VACCINATION.
NEITHER WILL THE MAYOR OF ST.
LOUIS.
>> WE DON'T WANT THIS TO TURN
INTO SORT OF LIKE A SHOW ME YOUR
PAPERS MOMENT.
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO TRUST WHAT
PEOPLE TELL US.
>> Reporter: THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH FOR THE KELLYs FROM
OREGON.
MASKED UP AND VISITING
WASHINGTON, D.C..
>> MY CONCERN IS IDENTIFYING THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND THOSE WHO ARE
NOT.
SO TO GO INTO A PUBLIC SPACE, TO
BE LESS THAN SIX FEET DISTANCED
BECAUSE I'M VACCINATED, I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT THE NEXT PERSON,
HOW HONEST ARE THEY GOING TO BE.
>> Reporter: DEBATE ABOUT
SO-CALLED VACCINE PASSPORTS,
PROOF OF VACCINATION, IS
INCREASING, AND SO PUSHBACK.
TAKE THE PROTEST THIS WEEK WHEN
LOCAL OFFICIALS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONSIDERED VACCINE
PASSPORTS.
BUT A PARADE IN KENTUCKY
YESTERDAY SERVED AS A REMINDER
THAT THE PANDEMIC STILL UNDER
WAY IS DEADLY SERIOUS.
[ SIRENS ]
30-YEAR-OLD OLIVIA TUTOR WAS
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL TO
WELCOMING NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS.
>> IT WAS A MIRACLE.
>> Reporter: SHE SPENT MONTHS IN
A COMA BUT DEFIED THE ODDS.
>> IN THE HOSPITAL, NOT EXPECTED
TO MAKE IT.
AND THEN THE PRAYER WARRIORS,
WE'VE GOT A GROUP OF THEM.
THERE'S A BUNCH OF THEM.
>> Reporter: NOW THERE WERE
THREE MAJOR STUDIES RELEASED
THAT REPORTEDLY HELPED DRIVE THE
CDC TO EASE MASK GUIDELINES.
THE FINDINGS ADD TO A GROWING
BODY OF EVIDENCE THAT THE
VACCINES ARE EFFECTIVE AT
PREVENTING SEVERE ILLNESS AND
DEATH FROM COVID, AND THAT THEY
HELP PREVE